this is the central station there are
tens of thousands of people coming in
and out and one of them i'm delighted to
say
is our colleague john sparks and his uh
team have just arrived on a long journey
from dinipro john
a welcome it's nice to see you in one
piece what was it like thank you adam um
about 21 hours on a very congested
train
it was hot it was packed people had
maneuvered themselves into any
slither of space
that they could get themselves in um and
it was extraordinary to see
extraordinary
to document and i have to say our
experience of course the experience of
myself and my colleagues nothing in
comparison to what the people in that
train were going through this was a
this was a journey
that was full of tears we saw people
crying particularly when they left the
station in uh dinipra
i think it's very very difficult for for
people in ukraine to believe that this
is actually happening i mean you've
spoken to people i've spoken to people
about a week ago who said i just don't
believe this would ever happen i don't
believe
that president putin would invade
ukraine and then some people saying well
if he does
we're going to kick their proverbial
butts but you know what it's things are
moving very very quickly and it's
difficult for
for people to come to to grips with that
and we were really we were finding that
on on the train it's it's it's difficult
people are scared
people don't know in many cases what
they're going to do when they get here i
think the general idea for many is is to
head to the european union but they
they've heard that the the queues in
poland are huge
some people were talking about going to
slovakia some to
romania so it's incredibly unsettling
and destabilizing for people many who
have children
many people there uh with with elderly
people as well and many people feeling a
sense of shame
as well shame that they
they are leaving that they are not
staying they're not going to stay and
defend their communities they may be
leaving their their elderly parents as
well so a lot of conflicting uh
emotions and we we got we got close to
that on the
on this trip
and one thing that strikes me so
strongly
is a relatively young nation it's only
what three decades old yeah
and what could be the destruction of
this nation is actually forging it isn't
it it's forging its identity
yeah that's that's a really good point
and that may have been one of the the
calculations on on behalf of the the
russians there is a sizable
russian-speaking minority here also an
ethnic russian
minority as well they may have assumed
that they they were going to get some
support they might get some backing in
places like harkeev where we were
earlier in the week what they have found
there
is that they will get virtually no
support no backing and now they are
they've tried to run armored columns
into that city that hasn't worked
now they seem to be in the process of
trying to flatten it and i think that's
one of the things that is so
frightening and so scary because we know
what the russians are prepared to do in
previous conflicts in in grozny in
chechnya in in syria in aleppo
and you know people know that you know
people
are aware of that they know
the potential for this conflict
to go on and they know how destructive
it can be and they've had to leave for
the most part they've had to leave
their husbands their brothers
in many cases their sons behind because
as you know martial laws now in place
men between the ages of 18 and 16.
cannot leave this country anyway and one
of the
very poignant moments for us when we
left at dinipro was that most of the
people who got on the train were women
and children the people waving goodbye
and often with tears in their eyes were
the men and
you know they don't know when they're
going to see each other again
john
it is very good to have you back uh
in one piece we're going to let you
have a have a bath and a cup of tea